herzlich willkommen bei einem spezialzug
zu die richtigen fragen hier direkt aus
kiew auf dem majdan den platz an dem
alles begann kann man sagen mit sehr
spannenden ersten session geschenke
berater beim ukrainischen präsidenten
residenz key buys wird lana die
künstlerin ist und selbst schutzwesten
aufbereitet bei dem zum reservisten
ehemals wissen der sich der zivilen
verteidigung angeschlossen hat und weit
bogdan einem fotografen der jetzt auch
hier im krieg
dieses geschenk so wir wollen mit der
situation
hierbei auf dem majdan beginnen du hast
hier in 2014 wie fühlst du dich jetzt
wieder hier zu sein umgeben von
sandsäcken und möglichen
artilleriefeuer ich denke sagt er der
mann ist überall in der ukraine vor acht
jahren war das hier der kampfplatz für
demokratie und jetzt denke ich ist die
ganze ukraine ein haben es als ein
schlachtfeld für die demokratie und ich
wiederhole noch einmal was ich schon
vielen journalisten gesagt habe wir
kämpfen nicht nur für die ukraine wir
kämpfen dafür um europa zu schützen vor
dem russischen diktator sie können mir
glauben oder nicht gut ihn wird
sicherlich nicht mit der ukraine
aufhören er will die nato zerstören als
institution institution er wird die
baltischen staaten angreifen oder polen
denn er ist nicht zufrieden mit dem was
in europa vor 80 jahren passiert ist
als junges mädchen als kind sozusagen
auf dem majdan da waren hunderttausende
von menschen wie fühlst du dich jetzt im
krieg zu sein
es sei wirklich furchtbar leid dass wir
hier hergekommen sind zu diesem zustand
dass wir wieder barrikaden
und
es ist furchtbar
so zu sehen das ist ganz schrecklich
dass es dazu kommen musste ich wollte
hinzufügen
wichtig ist jetzt für uns alles zusammen
den russischen idealismus
denn dieses großmacht streben der russin
hat sie dahin gebracht wo wir jetzt sind
und wir müssen den faschismus bekämpfen
du bist einer der verteidiger der stadt
muss ich sagen was woran kannst du dich
erinnern vom mai dann vor acht jahren
was ich war damals ja vielen dank für
die frage ich war einer der aktiven
verteidiger unterstützer und teilnehmer
der revolution damals und
wir hatten eine initiative e plus
bekommen so hieß das und der krieg
begann im jahr 2013 und er ist immer
weitergegangen nicht für einen tag lang
abgehört in denen wir kämpfen haben all
die jahre gekämpft für unsere gebiete
und wir haben
versucht
die leute zu schützen die außerhalb der
reine lieben erleben und sagen die sich
trotzdem als marina ölen in georgien zum
beispiel und dank deren unterstützung
haben wir jetzt unsere riesige
materielle und logistische unterstützung
außerhalb des landes
und länder wie die usa und
großbritannien und litauen und lettland
und estland haben
nicht direkt angefangen uns zu helfen ja
sagt aber wir werden auf jeden fall
darauf nochmal zurückkommt hattet ihr
erwartet dass der krieg hier in
beginnen würden nach dem was wir 2014
hier gesehen hat so viele menschen für
freiheit gekämpft haben also ich habe
ehrlich gesagt nicht glaube
die ukraine angreifen würde
als mir dann klar war
dass das passieren würde habe ich ein
bisschen mehr sachen mich mit ein paar
sachen vorrat aber ich hatte trotzdem
gedacht er würde ja nur um den don was
kämpfen ich hatte das konnte mir das
nicht vorstellen dass er das tun würde
was er getan hat was sagst du du hast ja
im präsidentenpalast gearbeitet mit den
beratern wie war die situation damals
ihr habt es nicht geglaubt bis zum
letzten tag oder ja bis zum letzten tag
des friedlichen lebens haben wir
geglaubt
das ist nur ein spiel
was er spielt um seine politischen ziele
zu erreichen
natürlich haben wir informationen
ausgetauscht mit unterschiedlichen
sicherheitsdiensten diese informationen
waren sehr widersprüchlich von der einen
seite erhielten wir starke signale von
den anderen eher weniger und es war
trotzdem eine überraschung für uns denn
ein krieg beginnt er niemals nach plan
nach zeitplan aber andererseits
hat die ukrainische regierung zwar
friedliche rhetorik eingesetzt aber sie
war natürlich auf alles vorbereitet als
der krieg begann du erinnerst dich ja
das war der bahn vorbereitet wir haben
russische panzer zerstört und nach einem
monat des krieges haben wir mehr als
100 flugzeuge abgeschossen und mehr als
500 panzer und
wie ist es jetzt dort im
präsidentenpalast ist es ist es immer
noch so dass die menschen dort sehr
nervös sind ja also die sicherheitsleute
die sind natürlich sehr nervös also
journalisten und so weiter also
diejenigen die nicht teil des der
sicherheits umgebung des präsidenten
sind
politisch gesehen ist alles okay der
präsident arbeitet etwa 20 stunden pro
tag er schläft nur sehr wenig diese
woche war besonders intensiv er hat vier
reden gehalten schwedisches parlament
nato europarat und
g7
habt ihr immer noch angst dass es
angriffe geben können ja auf auf ihn ja
natürlich er ist das ziel nummer eins
also die russischen aggression haben das
ja gleich von anfang an gesagt sie
wollen ihn angreifen und
es gibt diese geschichte dass raketen
direkt gerichtet waren auf seine
residenz und heute denke ich aber
relativ sicher ist
die hauptstadt ist besser vorbereitet
für diese art von vorkommnissen und ich
denke der präsident ist bereit er ist
bereit
da dazu keine kompromisse zu machen
svitlana viele frauen haben das land
verlassen verlassen sie sind hier
geblieben eine der wenigen wird das hier
in kiel für frauen und in der ukraine
insgesamt absolut normal
ich hatte nie den gedanken zu fliegen
ein app zu fliehen ich bin hier geboren
es ist meine heimatstadt und
ich habe einfach immer nur gedacht so
wenn ich irgendwie helfen kann dann muss
ich das tun und dann muss ich hier
bleiben so wie wir das jetzt hier machen
wir sitzen hier im regen in kiel sagt
paul ja ich habe heute zu den reportern
gesprochen und ich wurde immer wieder
gefragt warum investoren geblieben warum
bist du noch hier und ich konnte keine
geeignete antwort finden denn das stand
einfach gar nicht zur debatte mit de
hast du das gefühl also die leute in
deutschland wundern sich natürlich oder
fragen sich
ob die situation in kiew jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen besser geworden
ist also
es gibt starke kämpfe in libyen in
butscher
und wie ist die militärische situation
insgesamt
das militär die armee macht das größte
was sie kann und der geheimdienste tut
auch alles
oder spione in der stadt die nach
geeigneten momenten suchen um hier ihr
unwesen zu treiben und
versuchen
mich dafür zu tun damit die menschen
gehen der stadt verblieben sind sicher
sind
viele menschen sagt paul werden sich
fragen wie war das denn möglich dass die
ukraine bis jetzt dieser starken
russischen armee widerstand zu hause ja
erstens haben wir eine
gute gut ausgerüstete und erfahrene
armee sei 2014 damals war das noch zu
aber jetzt ist die armee viel besser
aufgestellt
haben dem stärksten moral
aller europäischen länder glaube ich
oder vielleicht auch der welt wir
vermuten um unser land wir schützen
unser land wir sind keine eroberer
sondern wir verteidigen und die menschen
die hier kämpfen kennen ihre region am
besten sie wissen am besten wie sie sich
positionieren müssen
sicher zu sein und um so man ihre
ressourcen zu schonen
was hier haben die munition und so
weiter die wir haben am effizientesten
nutzen wenn wir noch bessere hätten dann
würden wir sie noch viel schneller
umbringen können du hast als fotograf
gearbeitet sagt paul wie geht das ohne
geld und die wirtschaft ist nur
besonders gut aufgestellt was kann man
als ziviler als zu ihrer person shooter
also ich mache jetzt ganz andere arbeit
ich war kunstfotograf künstlerischer
fotograf eigentlich und ich habe nicht
gezählt aber sehr viele leute haben mich
direkt am nächsten tag anrollen
schrieben zwei tage später drei tage
später machen das immer noch und sagen
mensch was machst du denn da kommen wir
auch zu uns wir geben dir viel bessere
arbeitsbedingungen
und wir werden ja wenn man bücher hat
usw sieh dir abkaufen und ich zu
unterstützen ja also es gibt viele
finanzielle unterstützung
die beste oder das wichtigste thema
meines erachtens ist jetzt für die
ukrainer die frage der militärischen
hilfe
waffen von deutschland zu bekommen zum
beispiel frustriert zeit hier im
präsidentenpalast über die deutsche
haltung
also wir freuen uns natürlich über jede
art von hilfe und wir glauben
dass wir so viele freunde um uns herum
haben die können wir gar nicht zählen
und andererseits denke ich
dennoch dass die ukraine mehr hilfe
benötigt denn wenn russland anfängt uns
aus der luft anzugreifen da brauchen wir
hilfe ja sagt koll war das nicht von
anfang an unrealistisch
um eine flugverbotszone zu bitten was
ihr präsident ja immer zugesagt hat es
war ja klar dass die nato-staaten angst
haben würden involviert zu werden der
ukrainische präsident kämpft für die
ukraine deshalb
bittet er um soviel hilfe wie möglich
denn wir brauchen die unterstützung aus
der luft tatsächlich am boden ist die
ukraine sehr erfolgreich es sind
natürlich für soldaten gestorben leider
wir wollten das natürlich nicht aber sie
haben auch sehr viele panzer zerstört
und so weiter und ist es wichtig uns
selbst zu verteidigen
es muss nicht unbedingt eine
flugverbotszone sein
und auch kampfflugzeuge seien ja sagt
paul was braucht ihr aus deutschland als
trainer zum beispiel
sind die in einem guten zustand ich weiß
nicht ich habe sie nicht gesehen ja ich
auch nicht
ich denke wir brauchen oder es wäre gut
wenn wir
bessere
flugzeugsysteme hätten und stärkere
sanktionen denn das russische regime
wazir auf geld also öl und gas
sanktionen müssen auferlegt werden das
iranische szenarium zb also wenn ihr
energieträger abnehmen abnimmt und dass
mit geld bezahlten können kann das
russland natürlich verwenden für seinen
krieg also was militärische
es ist nicht nur wichtig den himmel
dicht zu machen wir haben drei meter
kann man nicht zu
das haben wir kapierten europa hat angst
vor einem atomschlag
aber europa hat er keine angst die
russen unser akw angegriffen haben und
der wind wäre ja dann auch die die
luftströmungen wenn hätten die
radioaktivität ja auch nach europa
gebracht aber gebraucht
und
wir brauchen natürlich bessere dinge als
systeme die 20 oder 30 40 jahre alt sind
ja das ist ein großes thema in
deutschland übrigens die deutschen sagen
wir möchten gerne helfen aber wir wollen
nicht zu stark involviert werden wir
wollen natürlich vermeiden dass dienst
aggression sich dann auf uns ausweitet
ich denke
dass deutschland als nation unter dem
stockholm syndrom leidet vom zweiten
weltkrieg her und möchte sie daran
erinnern dass die reine im zweiten
weltkrieg mehr als die hälfte seiner
bevölkerung verloren
wir waren eben
nicht im sicherheitsrat sondern in der
uno wir haben den größten preis bezahlt
allen republiken und wir haben diese
hilfe verdient und ich möchte sie daran
erinnern mein großvater zum beispiel ist
aus jenem krieg nicht zurück gekehrt ja
es wird lana du frierst wie ich sehe das
tut mir furchtbar leid es regnet so
stark wir haben auch von sanktionen
gesprochen dass kein öl und kein gas
mehr abgehoben werden sollte von rösler
wie sie gesagt hat die menschen in
deutschland ich bekomme viele e mails
und briefe die sagen man ja aber wir
haben nicht genügend geld das wird alles
so teuer wir können unser benzin nicht
mehr bezahlen wir können die heizung
nicht mehr bezahlen wir wollen kein
totales embargo weil das für uns zu
teuer wird unsere lebenshaltungskosten
würden dann zu stark steigen was würden
sie diesen menschen
antworten ja die ukraine ertrinkt im
blut und wenn ihnen das geld dann müssen
sie vielleicht ein bisschen sparsamer
seien bereits ein bisschen mehr zu
bezahlen und wie mitri gesagt hat
also geld ohne menschen
denken sie einfach noch mal drüber nach
wenn sie ein solches argument vorbringen
für mich ehrlich gesagt klingt das sehr
merkwürdig was für reaktionen habt ihr
bekommen aus deutschland ich bin
wirklich verärgert wenn leute mir
schreiben dass
als ihn leid tut und sie aber nicht
nutzen körnig wenn sie mir schreiben
aber ich weiß nicht was ich tun soll ich
habe kein geld übrig was ich beenden
könnte in wirklichkeit
menschen sehr viel klingen sie können
einfach ihre energie ein bisschen
effizienter nutzen und ihr geld für
aktionen verwenden sie gehen und bei
humanitärer hilfe zb zur
unterstützung der ukraine
informatorischen bereich und gleichzeit
frage ich dort für kulturelle
initiativen oder ich bitte sie darum
dabei zu helfen das ukrainische
kulturelle erbe zu erhalten in den
letzten wochen sind sehr viele museen
bombardiert wurden und alte gemälde sind
verbrannt
jedermanns kultur
was uns später allen leid tun wird wir
müssen das retten ja zum ende unserer
diskussion sagt paul buck dann würde ich
gern mal deine perspektive hören was
glaubst du wie lange wird das noch
dauern
also wir haben hier sandsäcke es gibt
luft aller
wir sehen die schrecklichen lage in
butter und in mariupol und anderen
städten was erwartest du was glaubst du
was in den nächsten wochen und monaten
passiert wird
wählen sie die
die schrecklichste und das wird dann
eintreten ja wie können sie sich mental
darauf vorbereiten ach ich bin hier
schon seit einem monat in dieser lage
ich bin mental vorbereiten und natürlich
mit lieb wir haben nur zwei
möglichkeiten entweder putin stirbt oder
wir gewinnen aber wenn er nicht wenn er
nicht stirbt
also ich denke wenn er tot ist wird die
armee kapitulieren ansonsten glaubst du
wird die russische armee weiter kämpfen
der fokus wurde gestern gesagt liegt
jetzt auf dem dünn was
ihre mütter lieben sie nicht
schicken sie in den tod in unseren
werden
menschen weil man sie austauschen
sollten dann oben der sie gegen und
steine austauschen unser land ist ein
wunderbares land wir haben ein sehr
fruchtbares land wir brauchen hier gar
keinen düngemittel zb und noch was
anderes sie haben nicht
die werden einfach verharrt und das
begreifen sie die sind kanonenfutter und
niemand kümmert es wenn sie sterben die
lana was glaubst du
bist du mental vorbereitet auf die
nächsten monate
was künstlerin du hattest diese
wunderbare stadt in der sie lebt ist und
jetzt diese stadt im krieg ich denke
sagt sie wir kämpfen nicht nur um
frieden sondern um unsere nackte
existenz und gleichzeitig kann ich es
nicht ertragen diese fried rhetorik
was bedeutet das leben
wenn verschiedene westliche experten uns
raten dieses oder jenes zu tun um
frieden zu erreichen
wir werden nicht aufgeben und wir wollen
frieden für unser land
du bist auch teil dieses prozesses oder
dieses progressive
du hast eine andere perspektive und
hören immer ja es gibt einen fortschritt
und dann sagst du plötzlich wieder es
gibt aber keinen fortschritt was würdest
du sagen wenn die wetten solltest wie
lange wird der krieg noch dauern nun
diese frage kann man heute nicht
beantworten wir können nur sagen der
wille der menschen zu siegen ist sehr
hoch also was was glaubst du welche
kompromisse könnte man machen
um ukrainische
sicherheitsgarantien das budapester
memorandum gilt nicht mehr
kein geheimnis das hat der präsident der
ukraine mehrfach betont dass die ukraine
leider in der nato nicht willkommen ist
und das ist eine der gründe weswegen
russland diese aggression begonnen hat
denn das haben sie erkannt dass es keine
wirkliche partnerschaft gibt zwischen
der ukraine und nato ja aber was für
kompromisse wärt ihr bereit einzugehen
mit putin wenn putin sagt okay wir
treffen uns nächste woche oder in zwei
wochen wenn ihr an einem tisch sitzen
würden würde welche kompromisse würdet
ihr eingehen das muss der präsident
entscheidend für heute haben wir keine
kompromisse
wie passt meint so lange es dauert tage
wochen monate ja wir waren letzte woche
bereit uns zu treffen aber sie waren
nicht bereit ihre ultimaten
aufzukündigen und
du meinst das ultimatum mit mario pohl
nein nicht nur zum beispiel auch wir
sind natürlich nicht bereiten krim als
einen teil von russland zu akzeptieren
also da seid ihr nicht bereit aufzugeben
nein natürlich nicht es ist ukrainisches
territorium
und so muss politik gemacht werden man
muss eine formel finden von
gegenseitigem interesse also es geht
nicht dass nur die eine seite ihre
interessen böse aber das bedeutet dieser
krieg wird niemals enden denn putin wird
auch nicht einlenken nein ich denke das
hängt auch von der militärischen
unterstützung für die ukraine ab es
wurden bereits starke sanktionen auf den
weg gebracht aber wir brauchen mehr
davon
ich versuche mir vorzustellen
sie leben in berlin und können sich
nicht vorstellen dass pankow oder
spandauer bombardiert wird und so
sieht's aus hier in kiew also wir sitzen
hier auf dem majdan und 20 km von hier
ist ein
richtiger ein echter krieg im gange
also
sympathisieren sie nicht einfach mit uns
oder haben sie empathie für uns aber
seien sie nicht arrogant unterstützen
sie die ukraine stärker
und
machen sie sanktionen unterstützen sie
militärisch und
ernährungssituation in der welt ist in
gefahr
ja schon sehr viele anzeichen dafür dass
es zu nahrungsmittelknappheit kommen
könnte diesem jahr wegen dieses krieges
ja zum schluss möchte ich noch mal
kurz
euch bitten in einem satz was wünscht
ihr euch von deutschland am meisten
bleibt an der seite von der ukraine
seit furchtlos und helfe der ukraine wie
ihr könnt
wir werden siegen unterstützen
wählt beim nächsten mal bessere
politiker
vielen dank für die starken statements
und ich möchte euch eines sagen
passt auf euch auf und überlebt bitte
das ist das wichtigste was ich euch
wünschen kein und euren familien einem
die richtigen fragen spezial hier vom
meiden wo 2014 die demonstrationen
passierten von wo aus alles ausging und
wo eine stadt mittlerweile mitten im
krieg ist